[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up man
not much i can't even
i can't see you because like
my
my camera that shows myself is right
over your face so i see myself twice so
this is actually much better for me this
is a good experience
as i i can see
it's in the same spot for me
and it's kind of driving me nuts i'm not
gonna lie because i would prefer to see
you
i could see you yeah
are you nervous
are you nervous for this show no a lot
of pressure on you no you know you know
great brothers
you know on step brothers when adam
scott is like
uh
either you f up and well i'm not gonna
fire you but either you f up and i get
to laugh at you or i look like a genius
to the board that's that's what this
show is for you this is the catalina
wine mix
have you ever seen the deleted scene
part of that where uh rob riegel's
character dies and then comes back like
has a heart attack and they're like no i
think he just died and they came back to
life i think i think i have
i think i have honestly that that's such
a good thing because there's the yells
the kobayashi thing and that's funny but
the in the deleted scene in the extended
version uh he dies but then comes back
to life
that's right
yeah
kansas guy
is rob real funny i do do you want to do
a minute on that like i don't think he
is
uh
eileen no honestly i really know
just like doing the same thing and every
he's doing the same thing he's good in
that role
he's good in that role i guess he's also
good
his character in 21 drops straight 22
jump street yeah i don't know if he's in
both of them but that's funny but yeah i
don't know i think i heard him on a
podcast once
and i was like eh not really sure how
funny this dude is he was kind of like
let's go let's get into it
are you ready ready to rock
we're doing it all right how are we
doing everybody
tonight is game one of the stanley cup
finals now
you're probably wondering where greg is
greg is currently on a flight to boston
to watch game six of the nba finals in
person um greg doesn't know anything
about hockey i personally also don't
know anything about hockey
that is why we are bringing in a good
friend of mine michael ritter to discuss
hockey this guy i hate to give him
credit but is an actual guru now ritter
i'm hearing
sources indicate that you have six bets
for us tonight that you love is that
correct that is correct six bets and i
got three for the whole series we got
that then we got three for tonight's
game i'm really really looking forward
tonight's game i've been deprived of
hockey for the last what five days i
haven't been able to just sit down and
do nothing but watch guys fight and
shoot pucks on net and we get to do that
tonight and that makes me very very
happy so as sam said we got six bets and
sam if you're ready i'm ready to start a
software now i'm ready to give people a
lock right over that
go do it one minute and we're gonna do
it go let it fly okay
see if you can see this this is the
first that we love nathan mckinnon
two and a half series goals we like the
over this bet jumped out to me
immediately i have no idea why this is
two and a half nathan mckinnon could
score a hat trick tonight and this bet
will cash in the first game he is in my
opinion there is a 1a and a 1b in hockey
conor mcdavid gets called the best
player in the nhl all the time i don't
think there's that big a difference
between nathan mckinnon and connor
mcdavid
this guy is outstanding he's like one of
the best goal scorers in the league and
the fact that draftkings is hanging at
two and a half minus 115 as you can
probably tell in this i totally forgot
to i started making the sign and totally
forgot to write the odds on it so that's
right down there at the bottom and
really small but it's minus 1 15. that
stuff happens uh but yeah the first lock
of this series minus two and a half
over for nathan mckinnon goals it makes
way too much sense i love it i love nate
dawg
we'll get to a little bit more about
that later but my second bet
can i can i comment on that pick first
can i want to comment yeah
absolutely yeah yeah obviously i don't
know anything about hockey that's why
yeah i'm handed up that's why we're
bringing in ritter to be our hockey guru
um i will say though the nathan mckinnon
goal against the blues in that one game
where he just went
side to side and just raced through like
seven dudes was the most electric thing
i've ever seen in my life uh so that
sounds like a fun as hell bet so i love
that for you ritter
it's i mean that's the best goal i've
ever seen in person i was at that game
we'll talk more about that
later as i mentioned but
that was his third goal of the game that
game and that's all we need we need
three goals but so you can catch this
tonight
you can catch this tonight exactly
i don't know i love it but all right i
don't want to hang you up too much get
in second bet second bet rapid fire
second day second bed second bet the
next bet is going to be a little
controversial because i just hyped up
nathan mckinnon because this is the guy
he's going to be going up against
so sam the mvp of the playoffs do you
know what that award is called
a little quiz i do everyone out there
i do because we have an
outline of the show
and it said the the name of the trophy
so i do know that but otherwise i think
i could have gotten it i think i would
have gotten it regardless but okay that
reaffirmed it
can i flip it on you yeah absolutely
yeah
who is khan smith tell me a fun fact
about khan smith can you do it i'm fraud
i have no idea who kind of fraud that's
i mean this is a this is a hole in my
hockey knowledge is not being able to
tell you who khan smith is who lady bing
is
who the heart trophy is named after i
don't know those things but we're
talking khan smite
and i have a bet before these playoffs
start my bet is the tampa bay goalie
andre vesilevski khan smythe plus 400.
so
he is
fourth
he has the fourth best odds to win con
smite the guys ahead of him are nathan
mckinnon kale mccarr who i'm sure we'll
talk about later as well
and vasilevskiy's teammate
nikita kucharov who's also at plus 400.
so
my thing is with this series that if the
lightning are going to win they are
going to win because of their goaltender
because he is the best goaltender in the
world he is the best goaltender that the
avalanche have seen so far i think the
abs are going to struggle a bit with him
especially tonight
but
i think when you're looking at khan
smythe it's almost always going to like
i don't think this is an award where
somebody just comes out of nowhere to
win
again it's a playoff award it is not the
stanley cup final award so this is a
resume of these three series before this
and andre vasquezki is the reason why
the lightning are here and i think
that's the reason why if he's going to
win the con smith or if they're going to
win the stanley cup and you need a con
smith bet i think it makes all the sense
in the world to have andre vesselski as
your pick now
so you want to comment on chime in do
you want to i'm commenting on it because
i just got to say i
my favorite part about doing these shows
is the chat throughout the show so i'm
reading comments in the chat right now
my favorite thing is while you are
talking michael underscore science stein
just dropped like eight thumbs downs
hated the pick which i thought was just
that's good energy hated the pic and
then ryan this is actually a good take
this is a good take from ryan smythe not
being pronounced like smith is criminal
um your take on that take
i mean it's probably canadian
and you know how can they like throw u's
and ease and crap like that sorry
probably shouldn't uh curse anyway i
think it makes sense crap is not a curse
okay cool uh khan smith just sounds
weird doesn't that i think khan smythe
actually sounds kind of cool yeah so
well i know
they went to college with connie smythe
and sloan kettering so
um
great great stuff hard
all right third bet go
third bet
the third bet for the series
is the series to go seven games at plus
210.
i
think this series is going seven games i
am betting it to go seven games i think
a lot of people are looking at the
series and they are saying the avalanche
are a wagon they are but the tampa bay
lightning what they have done
this postseason should be celebrated and
i think it's going to continue as we go
into this final round they took the
tampa bay or
the tampa bay maple leafs the toronto
maple leafs seven games who are arguably
one of the better teams throughout this
entire year
and they slipped up of course in classic
maple leafs fashion in the first round
in the seventh game
the tampa bay lightning swept the
president's trophy winning florida
panthers which was amazing no one
thought that was gonna happen you might
have thought the lightning was gonna win
that series maybe because of experience
but no one thought they were gonna sweep
them
and then they just took out and won four
straight against the new york rangers
against probably the second best
goaltender in the world
and now they're back for their third
straight stanley cup this team is really
effing good they're awesome and i think
we get so tied up with colorado and
obviously colorado is incredible they
have a little bit more star power
but
i think that this series is going seven
i also think it's just gonna be great
for hockey that this goes seven the nba
finals are about to wrap up the nba
finals if you didn't know actually wrap
up uh tomorrow on thursday when the
warriors will win the nba finals so then
we're all we're going to have peter pan
that's all we're going to count
chocolate that's all we're going to have
no i'm just i'm just saying facts i'm
not trying to grow up dude
but we're all we're going to have is
hockey and baseball and we just need we
need this to go seven and it's gonna go
seven plus two ten uh is the third bet
that we love
all right the chat the chat is really
rolling now and like i said get in this
chat this is this is where vibes are
made so michael stein
your biggest hater you might have to
have a 1v1 versus you and mikey
maggie stein said he hated the pick
because he's an abs fan and he don't he
doesn't want it to happen so it's
understandable um
a couple takes about the crap situation
joel crespo saying say poop instead that
maybe pivot the rest show if you if
you're going to say
crap just say poop i think that's a good
take yep uh fab classic maple leaves
which it you know that's they always
choke i know that everyone knows that uh
great great uh comment and avatar from
fab um
yeah and well fab also says this ritter
guy has good takes questionable takes on
on my end um all right fourth bet
four fourth bet okay so those were our
series bets now we want to get into
games let's actually i said actually
sorry let's do let's do the fifth bet
and then do the fourth bet so rearrange
your paperwork give me your fifth bet
yeah yeah yeah you won't do fifth bet
okay well the fifth bet
which i gotta keep you on your toes yeah
that's fair i got them lined up they're
all just sitting right here on the desk
uh yeah rearranged people aren't gonna
like this mikey stein i apologize in
advance this is about to be a rough
session for you here
lightning money line plus 140 is the now
fourth bet of the night this is our game
one pick i'm rolling with the lightning
tonight the abs have not played hockey
uh i'm gonna do a little call back here
since the coolidge administration uh
they're just been sitting on their bums
for a while yeah land for you good uh
i love the lightning tonight this is a
classic
uh team with a ton of experience playing
against a team people forget the abs
this is their first stanley cup final
since the bush administration right yeah
2001
and
also they haven't made it past the
second round of the playoffs
since then as well so this is their
first time this is a team again they're
rolling they're playing very well but
the lightning are built for this
situation and they have the best player
in this series in my opinion
which was supposed to be my you totally
threw this off mixing up the order but
you can translate it good
yeah you have to play through i had to
hit it off bigfoot like you you play
through the environment
frankenstein's fat foot uh and also
shout out god i messed it up i messed it
up yeah
riley steiner
mike steiner
mike steiner i guess is my biggest hater
in the app which i appreciate he's an
abs fan i like that but riley steiner
who is the app squad right today is also
on my side so everyone in the app is
riding with the lightning tonight and
then i did my handicapping and i was
like you know what i gotta go with the
lightning night and then now we can bind
so if you wanna roll with the app you
want to roll with us that is now my
fourth pick of the night but translating
into my fifth favorite pick of the night
i didn't want to write basketball i got
no no no no no
i am the conductor of the show i am the
golden god
let me do my thing dude no i'm just
kidding i i do there's a comment there's
a comment that i want to get to i love
the chat big track guy um someone just
asked
who's gonna score tonight do you now do
any of your bets have like a score pick
and if not you're gonna have to answer
the question and give a score pick right
now
i will give a scorer's pick i don't have
that as one of the six i'm going in the
opposite direction as we just alluded to
but we can do a little hey if you have a
goal scorer prop please drop it in the
chat right now i would love to talk
about that as i said that was moving on
to reflection on your end good
deflection on urine to avoid giving a
pic put it on the audience uh also
answer some good comments have asked
takes on the coolidge administration
which i think we can talk about the end
of that and then bagel unlock said we're
not going to talk about the rest uh i am
not equipped to have that conversation
so only ritter can do that all right
give me your
fifth bet that was your fourth bet
my fifth bet
is andre vasilevskiy over 32 and a half
saves i didn't want to write vasilevskiy
again so we're just going with vassy uh
because i was in it as a time crunch i
forgot that i am supposed to write all
these down so
vassi over 32 and a half days that
number is actually jumped and you
probably
it might be at 33 at draftkings right
now it was going up uh because it's a
great bet so if it's at 33 right now we
could probably check that honestly uh
still take it he's gonna have to make
like 36 saves tonight that's kind of
what i'm thinking because the avalanche
that's what they do they average around
36 shots
on goal a game and i think vasilevskiy
is good enough to stop all of those i
mean if you want a better shout out
tonight you can but that's i don't know
about that but andre vasilevskiy is i
said the best goaltender in the world
i'm betting him to win the con smite
trophy and i just think 32 and a half is
too low and i think the avalanche are an
avalanche of offense and they will be
peppering them all night the only thing
that worries me a little bit
is in the previous series for the
avalanche they have played teams that
are not exactly known for playing
defense that's a little bit different
with the lightning the lightning are
pretty defensive minded team they have
victor hedman uh sam that's that's a
buzzword name for you to remember is
victor hedman uh he is outstanding and
he will be a big part of if the
lightning can win this and just like
going back to that lightning money line
pick
the biggest thing why i wanted to take
that i know we got sidetracked with the
comments but i'll bring this back just
quickly is that if the game is going to
be a track meet the abs will win every
game you cannot win track meets against
the abs so i know some people are
thinking about the over under in this
game
i'm going with the lightning if you like
the lightning you probably like the
under if you like the abs you probably
like the over but it doesn't matter
because andre vasileski is making over
32 and a half saves tonight
now all right i'm going back
there i'm i'm always gonna i love the
chat this is the most fun part that we
get to we get to talk straight to the
people
um venecitos said how are the lightning
going to win when they are going to get
out shot 3-1 stop hyping their goalie
it's a team sport for a reason i do like
the vazzy saves pick tonight though
respect and he said six three abs
i feel like you're kind you're i mean
besides the who's gonna win i feel like
you agree with some of that right
absolutely and shout out for putting
respect it's always funny when people
like [ __ ] on your pick but they're like
respect it's like okay that's all right
so you weren't you weren't comfortable
you weren't you had to censor yourself
when you said crap and then just drop a
s-bomb when children are watching
we're talking about betting you got to
be 21 to vet we can say we can we can
say cusses we can do cusses i think the
producer was in my ear
you freaked out dude
dude i'm nervous i'm sweating like crazy
all right um
yeah now there's some good shot on goal
in the first minute minus 145.
someone
there's the name is tough does it
i'm not gonna try let's not forgive the
the abs are missing three key pieces
steven judah blitz mckinnon first goal
some interesting takes here yeah uh kids
are crying near ryan i mean that's
that's what happens when you act like
this on a show really recursive um all
right get into your elastic though last
bet last time i mean last bet last bet
last bet last bat last bit
that's beyonce's house this is house
the final bet the six bet that we love
tonight is
you knew it was coming the gift
the gift goal in first ten it is plus
100 at draftkings tonight i mean this is
the best bet in sports we know we know
why we love this bed
it's the best bet in sports because we
have a costume that goes with it
and the last time we wore this it cashed
and that game was in colorado and it
cashed so we're taking it what does the
card say what does the card say
uh it says it says something it doesn't
matter what it says um but it just know
it's again say it out loud why can't you
say it
it says uh two women from god
um
so it doesn't it i don't know when you
wore that out
interesting i wore it out in public um i
wore it to watch a hockey game people
loved it i drank a few beers in it i
think i might just wear it for the rest
of the show honestly it's pretty
comfortable um but that's great that is
what we're rolling with tonight as our
sixth bet is the gift somebody said
nathan mckinnon first goal i kind of
like that i'm not sure what the odds are
on that uh but i really like that i
honestly think that the lightning is
gonna score the first goal just because
i don't really like darcy kemper um and
they've also given up even in
i was at that abs game because i'm a
blues fan and the blues scored first
pretty often against the abs and the
lightning are way better than the blues
so i actually think the the lightning
will score first but they're going to
score in the first 10 minutes we're
gonna catch the gift and uh i'll be
wearing the costume uh when i'm at my
parents house watching the game tonight
so maybe we'll get some we'll get some
reaction of my mom being disappointed in
me
you when you do that you need to take
have someone take a picture of it and
drop it uh in the community stream in
the app so everyone can roast you um
we're i'm hearing sources are indicating
that uh mckinnon first goal is ten to
one that's pretty interesting
um
but ritter i gotta be honest i've got a
bone to pick with you and the chat does
too i mean you are getting obliterated
right now um no you're not i'm messing
with you but you just gave out six bets
for the stanley cup finals
and you did not give out one bet for who
is going to win the series
um that is unacceptable that is just
simply unacceptable um i want to move on
but i will give you
12 seconds to defend yourself
that's uh
honestly i just got excited about it
going seven that's that's all i care
about i want to watch seven games of
hockey i have a lean on who i think is
going to win this and i think i'll give
that out here in a second but uh hand up
uh
hand up both hands up just like this uh
i forgot
worried worried about you um all right
let's let's pull up some tweets here i
love to hear what people are talking
about on the twitter sphere uh i'm gonna
pull up uh a tweet right now
um for us to react to so
uh this is pretty much from proof of
sure hopefully i did that right pretty
much talking about how the abs uh played
a poverty goalie the entire postseason
and now that they're going against vassy
uh they're kind of gonna be in trouble
which kind of seems where you're leaning
but what's your take on that have they
have they kind of skated around playing
against poverty goalies and are now kind
of in trouble against vassi a little bit
so i would say that that has some truth
to it um they played nashville in the
first round nashville was like
kind of a tough team but not really
really the best goaltender they face is
jordan binnington and they faced him for
two and a half games
and he was outstanding against him and
then they played billy who so kind of
turned it on towards the end of that
series but i'm always thinking about who
they played last and they just played
arguably the worst goaltender in the
playoffs and mike smith and it showed
because they swept them they put up
eight goals on them in another game uh
this is going to be probably the biggest
difference and that's why i think like
if the lightning you're gonna steal one
they're gonna steal one in the first
game because they're going to be the
avalanche are going to be stunned when
they go from swiss cheese mike smith to
brick wall andre vasilevsky in in this
space
like mike smythe mike smith good good
call out uh but yes i i do really like
that take oh siri is hopping on to say
something uh but yes that's that's a
great tweak from uh poof for sure is
that what we're saying well you asked
sherry can you ask siri who she thinks
is going to win the stanley cup finals
now that you've brought her into the mix
yeah we get a third person here that's
great how do i do that my watch hey siri
who do you think is going to win the
stanley cup
finals say that the avalanche will
defeat the lightning by one and a half
goals
what oh
like half minus one enough enough
absolutely
this was not planned at all you know how
people know people come on and they do
shows and they like say it's not planned
but it's actually planned that that was
not planned at all the fact that siri is
giving out abs minus one and a half
uh that is absolutely wild we should can
we like clip that or at least like
that's that's a post right i mean as
minus one and a half from siri um that
is absolutely electric
um all right let's uh let's pull up one
more tweet um
let's pull up one more tweet that i saw
that i thought was interesting i want to
get your take on ritter um
can we can we get it up
there it is
all right
now
my first
take when seeing this tweet is
cake maker
can't be right so
dan rosen i'm assuming a typo i'll defer
to you
um
but pretty much uh
he yeah i mean he gave a quote he said
they're a team that's looking to become
a dynasty that then being the lightning
and we're a team that's looking to start
a legacy
um i feel like i have to call him cake
maker now even though it's not his name
just because of tweet but but what's
your thoughts on the quote
and
what's your thoughts on dan rosen's typo
so dan rosen's typo is egregious i guess
is the worst word or best word worst
word to de describe it uh
it's kale macar kale macar i know it's a
different food that we're talking about
here but
kale mccart you can't mess him up he's
the best defenseman in the nhl he's
amazing uh as far as the quote goes yeah
a great quote but
talk is cheap talk is cheap you could
say all this stuff bulletin board
material and everything like that
like sure if you want to fire up the
team but you might have also just fired
up the lightning the back-to-back
defending stanley cup champions so
talk is cheap you gave bullets and bull
board material to tampa
uh
yeah
cake mccarr cake maker that's what
you're gonna roll with now
pretty good um all right i have
i was gonna move on to the next section
and just like badger you for your series
picks but i've been in the lab i found
two more tweets that are are near and
dear to my heart that i would i would
like to go over right now so i'm gonna
try and pull them up um let's see if we
got them up so this one comes from my
critter and it says
speaking of bulletin board material the
abs suck yo
um interesting tweet uh i mean credit to
you for kind of getting in and out and
you know not burying the lead um but
that's one tweet um i think i i got a
second one that i'll try and pull up
here again new to hosting don't really
do abs are frauds
so
abs in the stanley cup finals favor to
win um
you have kind of given them some
bulletin board material and sort of
expose yourself as a fraud yourself um
defend yourself
yeah um those are those are not
photoshopped you said those are actually
my tweets
uh
because i confirmed nor did i
gotcha uh no those are my tweets uh i
think it's time to reveal myself as a st
louis blues fan so i'm probably a little
bit biased here and i think that the
aves succo tweet was whenever they
almost blew
a
giant goal lead in an 8-6 game against
mike smith in an edmonton oilers team
that wasn't any good they swept him i
get it but that was in in the moment
tweet and then the abs are frauds i i
think that came after my team beat them
at home twice and yeah we lost the
series and yeah mikey stein is probably
like oh this makes so much more sense
now but
uh mikey in the comments
yeah get mikey stein and make mikey sign
in but i think it's time to reveal my
lean uh for this stanley cup final i am
picking the tampa bay lightning to win
the stanley cup finals this year uh i'm
taking the plush money they're going for
the three-peat pat maroon gonna win four
stanley cups in a row
and you know what the abs are frauds
i'll say it the abs are frauds oh no
doubling down
you're going against siri
never watched a hockey game in her life
we're fine a bad take we're fine
ritter someone in the comments uh
all right so we like the lightning or at
least you do um again know we're
supposed to move on but i like to i like
to you know i like the chat i'm a chat
guy i just want to be in the chat the
entire time okay someone said
mckinnon to score 15 plus points for the
series which i thought was interesting
so let let me ask you this ritter
mckinnon points in the series or marcus
smart point i'm making up a bet on the
fly or marcus smart points tomorrow what
are you going with
wow pick the so who has more points
mckinnon's series are marcus smart just
tomorrow
yeah i
i'm going to go with the easy side and
say ma and say mark is smart i think
marcus smart can get probably close to
20 points tomorrow i mean if mckinnon
scores 15 points i mean
there's your i don't even know how to
contextualize that is that like that's
like a wreck so he's winning the cons in
my if he does that okay
100 like that's an amazing series that's
goals plus assists so he's
he's having an uh an amazing he's having
two plus goals every game or two plus
points excuse me every game if that
happens so i'm gonna go with mark smart
but i love that hypothetical we need
more of that kind of stuff
yeah that's a fun bet um we should make
that up all right let's get rolling um i
think you a little teased by you earlier
about the app um and how we are we're
taking a squad ride from the app uh that
gave out the lightning but there's also
you know once you're finished with this
show the community stream shout out to
the to our app folks michael bolling and
logan bagel and locks uh for you know
keeping our app community flowing um but
someone gave out the under today in the
app um and can we pull yeah we're
pulling it up right now now ritter gonna
be completely honest with you i am not
going to read that now i appreciate kev
that it's i'm sure it's an electric cap
a lot of words
max the producer of the show sent me an
article today i said make a tick tock
for it i'm not reading that so that's
kind of where my head's at so i'll just
ask you under good bet bad bet
your take on kev's take
the kev
87. two thumbs up on this pick i will be
tailing this tonight as i mentioned
earlier if you like the lightning you
like the under tonight this is again
going to be a big shock to the system
for the avalanche
right off the bat
and again vasilevskiy he's going to make
stops the lightning are not like they
have amazing offensive power and also we
have failed to mention that brayden
point is back tonight for the lightning
that also plays into my pick tonight
that was awesome to see right in point
just just an electric especially
postseason player
obviously you're a little bit concerned
with his first game back and it's game
one of the stanley cup finals but he is
just one of the best players in the nhl
and i can't wait to watch him back
tonight we have nikita kutcher off we
have steven stamkos andre pilat
the lightning are going to hang as i've
mentioned repeatedly throughout this
episode they're going to hang with the
avalanche and i think they're going to
win tonight and i think it's a 3-2 game
i do worry a little bit if you could
find a six and a half but it looks like
draftkings putting that six out right
now i still feel very comfortable with
that uh but yeah all about this under
tonight and i can't wait to see that the
avalanche went eight to three and i look
like a complete idiot not that i don't
look like a fleet idiot right now uh
wearing this costume but we've had worst
moments before for michael ritter so if
the as blow him out tonight ridiculous
fashion i'm sure we'll hear about it and
i'll make sure i defend myself in the in
the app community for this one uh but
yeah love the under tonight great pick
kev
love that love love the community vibes
all right ritter we are we are running
out of time here i do want to take some
questions from the chat from the
community but run out of times i want a
rapid fire here i'm just going to throw
[ __ ] at you i just want you to tell me
really quick yay nay move on um keep
keep your takes quick all right so here
we go rapid fire uh so
this is from z schwartz19 is cole mccar
over 0.5 power play points free tampa
takes most penalties and macar is the
power play qb
take on his take uh
absolutely love steve schwartz kale
mccarr i spoke on him earlier absolutely
love him avalanche score tonight i know
that kind of conflicts with the under in
my bet but he's electric and like you
said he's he's the power play god in my
opinion so if you can find a 0.5 power
play points i mean he's going to get an
assist if they score a power play oh
that's just how it goes
all right ale bella says he's just given
he or she is just giving us a pick some
great value under two-ish half shots on
goal from stamkos it looks way too easy
looks way too easy to go over
believe me i've been around this for
over 35 years your take on his take or
her take
it sounds like we're talking to a sharp
so if you got the stats to back that up
like that and saying that you're a
seasoned vet
maybe it is too easy i i won't i won't
stop you there like like it keep keep
dropping those kind of fixing that's
crawl that's awesome
um
some more takes bolts and five plus one
thousand your thoughts on that dude are
you gonna mess around with any of the
exact words
uh i probably won't but if you're
feeling frisky i mean again they swept
the florida panthers who were considered
the best team all year who knows
plus one thousand that's that's frisky
all right and our final question which i
touched on earlier but didn't get a good
answer for this one comes from fab uh
just your overall takes on the calvin
coolidge administration what do you
think worked and what do you think did
not work
uh so he was silent cal he didn't he
didn't speak up enough we we need we
need more vocal leaders so i'm going to
give i'm going to don't bring politics
into this show don't bring politics and
just give it a like
give it like a c minus administration
sorry sorry calvin r.i.p though
all right that will do it for us uh
appreciate you uh ritter rapid fire
before we go your six bets
give them to me in like 30 seconds just
go
all right if anyone misses
if anyone missed this electric half hour
mckinnon over two and a half goals in
the series vasilevskiy khan smythe award
plus 400 series to go seven games plus
210 andre vasilevskiy over 32 and a half
saves tonight lightning money line it's
called app squad ride and
the gift
plus 100 at draftkings
that's it for me go lightning cabs and
frauds
thank you for watching peace
[Music]
[Music]
you